[Music]
decades ago
people had to get out of the car when
arriving home in order to open the
garage door
today it's routine to open and close
your garage door at the push of a button
either on a wall mounted pad or on a
remote control
a garage door opener's motor drives
either a belt
a chain or a screw rod like these models
in turn they move a carriage connected
to the garage door
at this factory the production line
starts and ends at the same place
they take one completed garage door
opener off the line
then start a new one by attaching a
power cord to the unit steel chassis
[Music]
then they place the chassis onto a
traveling assembly fixture
and plug in the power cord to prep the
unit for testing later
they place the unit's plastic housing
next to the chassis
then snap in the plastic safety cover
this goes over the direct current motor
the equivalent of one and a quarter
horsepower
they attach an optical encoder to the
motor
the encoder is a sensor which reads the
door's position
so that the motor knows when to stop
moving the carriage
they place the motor against the safety
cover then screw it in place
in the housing they install the motion
sensor
it turns on the opener's light as soon
as you walk into the garage
or when the garage door opens
next are the switches for programming
the remote control
and for setting the travel limits these
are the points to which the opener must
move the door to fully open and close it
they then install the circuit board
routing the antenna for the remote
control receiver to the outside
they plug in the motion sensor cable
then wire and plug in the connector for
the light bulbs
and fasten the board in place with
screws
they attach the electrical ground wire
to the chassis
connect the power cable and then the
optical encoder to the circuit board
with all the internal components
installed now they affix the housing to
the chassis
this completes the brain of the garage
door opener called the operator unit
[Music]
an automated testing machine now checks
all the functions
simulating the load of the garage door
it also checks the light bulb sockets
and the connection ports on the circuit
board for the safety beams
the beams stop and reverse the closing
door if they detect any object in its
path
once the operator unit passes inspection
it comes full circle
to the end which is also the start of
the production line
a plastic lens to enclose the light
bulbs and the unit comes off the line
the carriage rail is milled from
galvanized steel
it has slots for locking in plastic
liners which hold the screw rod
to produce the screw rod the factory
machines a solid bar of steel
to the required dimensions and profile
then with high pressure rollers it forms
threads in it
workers insert the screw rod into the
liners in the rail
for the retail market rather than
produce one long rail and screw rod
the factory makes three shorter
connecting sections that fit into a
smaller package
this machine lubricates the screw rod
with grease
it helps it rotate smoothly in the rail
liner when the opener's motor is running
when the screw rod turns teeth on the
base of the carriage
interlock with the threads moving the
carriage along the rail
workers first install the carriage base
at the factory
then they pack all the garage door
opener components for shipping
starting with the rail sections
and the operator unit
last to go in are the wall mounted
control pad the remote controls
and the safety beams which you install
on each side of the garage door opening
when you install the garage door opener
you insert the screw rod into the
motor's drive shaft
then you assemble the rest of the
carriage connecting it to an arm which
attaches to the garage door
motor runs screw rod turns carriage
moves
and your garage door opens or closes